AI just crossed a line that nobody saw
coming. You're not prompting it anymore.
You're deploying it like an actual
worker. GPT 5.4 doesn't just answer
questions. It opens apps. It clicks
buttons. It writes code. It runs your
entire workflow from start to finish
without you touching a thing. Developers
are using it to build entire SAS
products with a single prompt. Business
owners are using it to automate customer
support, data analysis, content
pipelines, and lead follow-up all on
autopilot. And the crazy part, most
people have no idea this exists yet.
We're not talking about a chatbot
upgrade. We're talking about AI that
actually does the work, the boring work,
the repetitive work, the stuff that eats
your time every single day. This is the
shift from AI as a tool you use to AI as
a worker you deploy. Today, I'm going to
show you exactly what GPT 5.4 is, what
makes it different, and the real
workflows people are building with it
right now. Let's go. Hey, if we haven't
met already, I'm the digital avatar of
Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO agency Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
make sure you comment below and tell me
what workflow you'd automate first.
Actually, is GPT 5.4 is OpenAI's latest
Frontier model. But calling it a chat
model is like calling a Formula 1 car a
family sedan. technically true
completely misses the point. This model
was built from the ground up for one
thing, doing real work inside real
software environments. It's available in
chat GPT, the API codeex development
tools and IDE integrations. So whether
you're a developer or a business owner,
you can plug it into your workflow right
now. But here's the key thing to
understand. Old AI gave you answers. GPT
5.4 takes actions. You give it a goal.
It makes a plan. It picks the right
tools. It executes the steps. and it
delivers the result. That loop, plan,
act, observe, verify, continue, is what
makes this an agent, not just a chatbot.
There are four features you need to
understand. These are the reasons why
developers are excited about this one.
The first is native computer use. GPT
5.4 is the first generalpurpose open AI
model that can actually control a
computer. Not in a demo way, in a real
practical way. It reads screenshots,
moves the mouse, types commands,
navigates websites, and operates desktop
apps. You can pair it with tools like
Playright, and it will control a browser
like a human would, except faster and
without making typos. The second is tool
search. Old models had to load every
possible tool into the prompt up front.
That was slow, expensive, and clunky.
GPT 5.4 searches for the tool it needs,
grabs it, uses it, then moves on. This
means smarter workflows, less wasted
processing, and way more flexibility
when you're building complex systems.
The third is a massive context window.
We're talking up to 1 million tokens in
certain environments. That means the AI
can read your entire codebase, your full
document library, your whole product
catalog all at once and actually
understand how everything connects. For
businesses, this is huge. It means AI
that understands your whole operation,
not just a fragment of it. The fourth is
true agentic workflows. This is the big
one. GPT 5.4 is designed to run
multi-step tasks automatically. It
doesn't need you to hold its hand
through every step. You give it a goal.
It works out the path, executes the
actions, checks the results, adjust if
something goes wrong, and keeps going
until the job is done. Quick pause here.
If you want to learn how to build AI
workflows like these for your own
business, the AI profit boardroom is
exactly where you need to be. We go deep
on real AI automation systems, practical
tools, and step-by-step processes that
actually work. No fluff, no theory, just
real systems you can implement. Check
the link in the description and come
join us. Let's get practical. Here's
what people are actually doing with this
right now. The first workflow is the
autonomous coding agent. You describe
what you want to build. GPT 5.4 for
generates the architecture, writes the
code, runs the tests, catches the
errors, fixes them, and deploys the app.
For example, if you wanted to build a
custom onboarding quiz for a membership
community that matches new members to
the right resources based on their
business type, you just describe that in
plain English. GPT 5.4 handles the front
end, the back end, the logic, and the
output. No developer required. The
second workflow is the AI content
pipeline. Research, scripting, slide
creation, thumbnail ideas, scheduling,
all handled automatically. You'd give it
a brief like write a complete YouTube
script explaining how AI automation
saves agency owners 10 hours a week
include a punchy title, key talking
points, and a hook for the first 30
seconds. One prompt, full content asset,
ready to publish. The third workflow is
the AI data analyst. It downloads your
spreadsheets, cleans the messy data,
generates charts, writes the insights in
plain English, and sends the report.
You'd prompt it something like, "Analyze
this member growth data. Identify which
traffic sources are converting best this
quarter, and give me a plain English
summary with three clear action points.
Done. No spreadsheet skills needed." The
fourth workflow is browser automation.
It searches the web, collects structured
data from multiple sources, extracts
exactly what you need, and saves it all
to a database. You'd say, "Search the
top AI automation communities and
forums. Collect the 20 most common
questions people ask about AI tools for
business and save them to a Google sheet
formatted for content planning. It runs
the whole thing while you do something
else. Here's the one that genuinely blew
people's minds when they saw it. A full
CRM automation system built with one
prompt. Someone fills out a lead form on
your website that GPT 5.4 for reads
their answers, qualifies the lead,
decides if they're a good fit, writes a
personalized outreach email based on
exactly what they said, logs all their
details into your CRM, and schedules an
automatic follow-up for 48 hours later.
It's all of it. No human in the loop.
The prompt to make that happen looks
something like this. You are an AI
assistant for a business community
focused on AI automation. When a new
lead submits a form, qualify them based
on their business size and goals. Write
a personalized welcome email that speaks
directly to their situation. Log their
details with a lead score and schedule a
follow-up automatically. That's it. That
one prompt runs the entire system. This
is what AI workers actually look like in
practice. Let's talk numbers because
these actually matter. On SWEBench Pro,
which tests real world software
engineering tasks, GPT 5.4 scores 57.7%.
That's a better result than a lot of
junior developers would produce on the
same tasks. On OS World Computer Use,
which tests the model's ability to
navigate and operate a computer, it
scores 75%. That's not a toy result.
That's a serious capability. On browse
comp, which tests deep web research and
information extraction, it scores 82.7%.
These are independent benchmarks used by
researchers. The model isn't just
impressive on paper. It's genuinely good
at the kind of practical real world
tasks that matter for running a
business.
All right, let's wrap this up. GPT 5.4
is not just another model release. It's
the first serious signal that AI is
moving from something you use to
something you deploy. Computer use, tool
search, long context, and true agentic
workflows. Those four things together
make this the most capable work tool
we've seen yet. If you want to go deeper
on how to use AI systems like this to
actually build and grow your business,
join the AI profit boardroom. We cover
real workflows, real tools, and real
automation systems that you can start
using immediately. Link is in the
description. And if you want the full
SOPs, templates, and over 100 AI use
cases, like everything we covered today,
join the AI Success Lab. It's our free
community with over 40,000 members who
are all using AI to work smarter. You'll
get all the notes from this video,
access to the full resource library, and
a community of people actually doing
this stuff. Links are in the comments
and the description. Drop a comment
below and tell me which of these four
workflows would you build first. So
Julian reads every single one.